how's it going resumes purity Pat
welcome back to some more prop hunt uh
I'm gonna get a high vantage point I'm
gonna try to find him okay good make the
the noise of an eagle if you see them
okay that's enough don't sound like ice
over here kid
oh look at it look at how confused a oh
wow see this ha ha where I am enough
games I'm staying here I'm keeping an
eye out okay I don't think it's working
stay right what are you doing to me oh
nothing this beanie goes for me make
that Eagle noise that you always make oh
it's not a table what yeah Oh who's
appeals a hollow Leo's are here no no
I'm not a bottle I never wear a bottle
and I never oh [ __ ] [ __ ] okay I got away
I got away don't worry about it okay I
am in a bit of a pickle
yeah I am eating a pickle I I mean I
need you to help me worry I can help you
you see me yeah I did see you then you
ran away but I'm scared that they might
come for me where okay he looks leet you
got to get me out of this situation man
what are you I don't understand can
their guns die that's where they're
gonna be stuck oh they are you can move
I say moving okay what are you doing
they're out sign shits I can't stop my
buddy push me hard we're saying I'm
trying to get ha ha ha
what are you but you're no rockin out -
damn it
Oh No let's push me out you left seat
big I can't go out like this
whoa it's like I'm swimming like a seal
please before they get here please push
me out
wish me out with better yes oh god that
did not last long so look for large
objects if he's stuck
hmm I know where it is I don't exactly
where he is really
head back to the conversation so what do
you want for christmas if you wanted
something like let's say you wanted to
be an object that was very festive in
nature and you were Felix what um hey I
know what you're doing I don't like it
no no no no oh you get a gun out Mouse
what yes okay I'll see Nana's up all
that ha ha ha ha
Alex woody up appears on the run they'll
never find me Felix
I swear I'm gonna lose it it are you
breaking the rules right now no I'm not
run anything you could do it you could
do it good crime is ghost quick gonna
say you're just standing there that's
why I'm really humbly I got 10 hit him
because Dom made it safe and sound
that's what you think
do telephone each other good phone I
swear to God what is that
I'm nothing you don't know me you think
you know me huh no you don't shut up oh
let me go please take the table follow
me follow me take it let's go
follow me yes yep I got a great one
I got a great one I'll follow you I'll
follow you to death should probably hold
on baby cake all right
you see what I'm thinking are you
thinking what I'm you are okay really
this is the best plan we have here hey
hey I get up don't take it until I'm
gonna get a little job security over
here okay what the hell man yeah the
plan yeah we had a deal we were partners
yeah listen oh it's like I'm the first
line of defense slash I'm cowering in
the corner it's true the wait wait if
I'm like this it looks like I'm like an
ornament up [ __ ] ah gee freaking bucket
on a gazebo oh no I was an ornament on a
gazebo
it's different what I can't tell you
anymore look at me
this is so good look at me Candice me
look at me this is genius it's protected
and some side of things that's all I'm
gonna say hey what are you looking at I
don't judge
Gavin constantly yet you like a free
story let me go I didn't do anything
Thanks I can't risk and Ken all right
what really Ken really don't hate him I
spot really see what is he
outside is bad no which one of us are
close to him which one right Tom I don't
know just went outside but there go joy
no that was it's okay mark come back
that would we I should be really you get
me right away now Ken exactly the same
[ __ ] spot white oh oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no my is right oh Ken
come in no look at me
oh no oh no whoo no what do I do oh no
it's okay just chose this jump hey Joe
do you have a life worth living
I'm using all my inheritance when I die
which I'm already dead okay Joe get jump
the plank jump the bank no wait I'm Jim
I'll feed him to the alligators Oh John
we're here to talk you every two seconds
you have so much to live for
you have three seconds to jump they give
you a family I will find you
now you you're looking good again
ticular set skills that's not gonna work
oh [ __ ] oh no no goddamn no offense but
I would find a hiding spot if I were you
whoa hey hey I got a great no no no no
this is a thing the door there uh wait I
ran into you there you don't yeah there
you go
no wait other side yes no other side
other yes yes no stop I'm not on it
oh you're not oh my gosh you what is
going on and worse yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're good you're good you're going on
you're gonna want it no you're good oh
okay yeah I gave you a hint it's a
it went back down inside the be rated
earlier it's drunking Tony can't bear
Holly what are you that's not great
freakin Ike's but what a cold
oh it's pretty uncool Jesus you you were
stolen okay you hotter evil what so hot
Oh
oh my god it's bursting hi love it's
boiling over all those bunnies back you
know where our best hiding spot ever
standing up top of me you were my
freakin liar it'll be two come on whoa
oh my god that is so good that's our
Oh kudos oh can I get this I'm an eagle
oh look at you Wow yeah hey come down
beneath me and catch me
okay I'm come see that tunnel down there
that's my pool
okay okay you say that and you catch me
okay the pool and I want you to sing
that song and every night in might think
that Sun everybody
catch me catch me catch me I've ever
seen this is okay get out of my face I'm
stuck in your face get stuck I don't
know what happened alright cutscene I
think they're stuck hang on
are you guys sure take me move please
hey don't shoot don't shoot in I have a
plan okay I can do it
I can't even kill him but for so Milly
ating alright friends I hope you enjoyed
another episode of prod punt don't even
like if you did it helps me out a lot
I'm so happy to see you brother I dig in
this series let me know if you want more
and subscribe to become a bread today
and I've seen the next one have some
bread love you
Oh
ah